it is a harbor heavy with the traffic of
the oil industry Aberdeen is this
country's oil tone has been for 40 years
and will be for decades more according
to BP at least whose laces 4 billion
pound investment has been endorsed by
the government the prime minister left
behind controversies at Westminster for
a day trip north and the fresh air of
jobs and investment congratulations on
this landmark investment the scale of
which I think hasn't perhaps sunk in on
all of our fellow countrymen who
probably like me remembering vaguely
their geography GCSE or in my case I'm
afraid o level thought that North Sea
oil was running down it isn't there are
many many years left of this great
natural resource mining the North Sea is
big business around ninety percent of
the UK's oil and fifty percent of gas is
supplied by British companies but
today's production is only around half
of what it was a decade ago there are
still hundreds of oil and gas wells off
the northeast coast of Scotland the BP
money will go into the clearfield west
of Shetland to steal platforms will be
built to mine an estimated 640 million
barrels of oil will provide many
hundreds of jobs in the UK and
engineering and drilling oil field
services jobs over the field life this
is in addition to the 600 people working
directly on this project right now BP
has renewed his focus on the North Sea
after his disastrous oil spill in the
Gulf of Mexico in April last year from
beneath the north sea surface the
company says it could be extracting oil
to the year 2050 and Beyond but
environmentalists ask at what cost it's
far more difficult to deal with an
accident there that wasn't a relatively
benign conditions to the Gulf of Mexico
you need thousands of people hundreds of
ships billions of pounds to even begin
to address the kind of problems that
could could result in the blossom
region the United Kingdom is desperate
not to be over reliance on foreign fuel
but David Cameron's difficulty is in
balancing the interests of the economy
with the interests of the environment
and the environmental lobby North Sea
oil is an uncertain right but for these
offshore workers returning to news of
investment along with everyone else in
the industry there is the reassurance
that they'll be making the return trip
for many years to come James Matthews
Sky News Aberdeen